I used to smile a lot; I was strong.
Here, on this picture, I was 16 or 17.
That’s me with a friend here - we were so
happy back then.
Handan Aşkin enjoys looking at her old pictures.
She likes to remember her teenage years.
But there’s one person she’s torn out
of all the photos: Her husband.
The man who nearly killed her.
Throughout the 10 year of our relationship,
he hit me, he beat me, he insulted me.
(short pause) It happened in the bedroom,
too…
One day – and I will never forget it – I
went to work with a black eye and split lips.
I didn’t want to get fired – HE wasn’t
working.
But then, Handan couldn’t take it anymore.
She wanted to leave her husband.
There is video footage of what happened next.
One day, he approached her with a gun.
And shot her.
I thought: This is it.
I am going to die.
I was on the ground, injured - he put the
gun in my mouth and pulled the trigger – but
he had run out of bullets.
That was my second chance.
(Thank God.)
For two-and-a-half years, I have been re-living
that moment over and over again.
I try not to let anyone notice - neither my
children, nor the people around m).
But over and over, in my dreams, I see this
man trying to kill me.
Since then, Handan has been paralyzed from
the waist down.
Her husband is in detention.
On paper, they’re still married.
His trial for attempted murder has been dragging on for over two years…
Today, there is another hearing.
Her brother, Sedat, accompanies Handan to court.
She’s actually is entitled to a driver,
paid by the municipality.
But that often doesn't work out.
Instead, she takes a taxi.
Handan hates these court dates.
The prospect of having to see her husband again scares her.
I want him to receive the toughest punishment
possible.
Five or ten years are just not enough for
what he put me through.
Reliable data on violence against women in
Turkey is scarce.
But what little DOES exist suggests the numbers
are rising…
The women we talk to in Istanbul confirm this:
We’ve all experienced abuse – be it physical,
or psychological.
Of course, there is violence against women
here, and reports on women being murdered
are increasing – we’re sick of it!
My neighbor beats his wife.
I think it’s out of jealousy.
But many men beg to differ.)
I haven’t noticed anything.
If I had, I would have intervened.
In our culture, women are the most precious
thing we have.
Beating a woman is completely unacceptable.
Handan and Sedat have arrived at court.
Her lawyer is already waiting.
Gül Erdoğmuş has represented many women
who have fallen victim to violence.
The Turkish government stresses it’s taking
the matter very seriously – and recently
published THIS video:
The message: Zero tolerance for domestic violence.
The government needs to do more to protect
women than release videos like this.
Our society dictates so much to women: How
they should dress; that being a housewife
and mother is the best career for them...
These are the messages our politicians are
constantly sending.
It’s time for Handan to enter the courtroom.
The trial against her husband continues.
TV cameras are not allowed inside.
A courtroom artist captures the moment.
Her husband is just a few meters away.
She tries not to look him in the eyes.
The judge is admitting a new psychiatric report
as evidence, confirming the defendant’s
criminal liability.
Then, the trial is adjourned.
Again.
Outside, a few supporters are waiting.
The activists regularly visit trials like
these.
Their signs say: “You are not alone.”
For a long time, I was afraid.
But not anymore.
My health has been ruined.
I probably won’t ever be able to live in
happiness and peace again.
That’s why I say to the women here in Turkey:
Don’t be afraid.
Of anything!
You are strong!
In a few weeks, Handan will return.
When the trial against her husband continues.
The man who nearly killed her.